ではよろしくお願いします
えーと 今日は聖者と凡人の苦しみ方が違うというテーマになります
これという苦しみはないんだぞというならばね
話はなりませんでしたけど
まあ一応 一般的に仏教ではね
人間には苦しみがあるという立場で話しているんです
それはそれで簡単なことではないんです
決して人間には何の苦しみもないというふうな教えも世の中にはあるんです
世の中は完璧だ 完全だとかね
何も間違ってるものはないんだぞというふうな考え方もないわけじゃないんです
しかし 仏教の立場っていうのは
世の中は不完全であると
完全なものは完璧なものは何もないんだと
不完全だったらいろいろトラブルが起こるでしょうしね
ですから まあ人間の体も心も全部不完全ですから
いろんな問題 トラブルが生まれてくる
それから苦しみも生まれてくる
それでまあ 聖者と凡人の一般の人の差は何なのかと
はい で まず考えてほしいのは
苦しみ なんか字が抜けてます
苦しみといえば何を指すのかっていうことなんですね
苦しくっていうのは 2つあります
私たちは考える 怯える
苦しみ  いわゆる私たちはこれが苦しみだと思って怯えている苦しみがあるんですよ
また 仏教が強調する しかし凡人は気にしない苦しみ
この 2つあります で  1つの苦しみっていうのは
私たちはやっぱりそれだったらもう嫌だよとかね
それだったらもう怖いそうというふうな怯えている苦しみが我々にはあります
であんまり仏教はそういうことには関心なさそうで
仏教は苦しみだと何か教えているんですけど
一般的には私たちはあんまりそれはあ
そうかということで 無視するというかね
気にしないんですね はい
そこで私たちは考える
怯える 苦しみっていうのは具体的に何なのかということは考えた方がいいんですよ
すごいわかりやすいんですよ
社会人として 人間として成功することこそが絶対的な生きる目的だと思っているので
誰でもそう思っているんですね
社会で成功しなくちゃいけないんだと
人生はなんとか幸福にならなきゃいけませんという
それが我々の生きる目的なんですね
そういうふうに思っているんだから
俗世間で成功できるかないかは怯えている
よくよく見ると 私たちはもう社会で成功できるかな
失敗するだろうかなとかね
そんなことに苦しんでるんですよ
えらい悩んでるんです
うまくいくでしょうかとかね
自分を認めてくれるでしょうかとか
そういうことにはよく悩んでます
例えば 落第することやリストラになることやら失業
そんなものを怯えている
それは少々違うかもしれませんが
失敗ですね で そうなったっても人生は成功できんだからね
落第しちゃうともう何も成功できないし
リストラになってしまえばね
全然気分よく仕事できるわけじゃないし
怯えちゃうんでしょうに
失業もものすごい怯えることでしょうに
やっぱりその場合でも
自分が失敗だとね 社会で成功していないんだということにすごく落ち込むんですよ
で またもう引いて考えちゃうと
周りの人々とうまく付き合えないことが苦になる
これも人間にとっては
よく我々にもね いろんな相談したり
質問されたりする場合は
よくあることっていうのは
リストラになったらどうしますか？って言ったってもね
私にどうすることもできないんだからね
あまりそういう質問はされませんんだけど
まあこれは聞けますね
あまり周りの人々と上手にうまく付き合えないんだと
人間関係 それで我々にとっては
自分が社会に認められて
よくチヤホヤされてくれるんだったら
それこそすごい最高幸せなんです
もしうまく関係はいかない場合はね
これがものすごく苦痛で苦しくて
どんどん精神的に落ち込んでしまっちゃうんですね
だから俗世間では人間関係ももう大変な苦しみなんですよ
次にこの財産がなくなることもまた苦になっちゃいますね
当たり前のことで 大体みんなもう財産がなくなったらどうしようかと
時々この今はどうか分かりませんだけど
この人々っていうのはお金を貯金するんですね
老後に使うためとか それでなんか貯金があるぞとわかっちゃう
わかると年取った人にまあ誰かが若者というか
若い人たちは近寄るんですよ
なんか親切な顔をして
であれは金を奪い奪い奪いたいだけのことなんです
それでまあ奪われる時もありますけど
騙されて で 老人の人々っていうのはかなりケチというかね
ぎゅっと この人は私のお金を奪いたくて近寄ってくるんだと
私に親切ではないんだととかね
そうやって怯えるんですよ
時々まるっきり一人で
もうずっと鍵やら窓やら玄関全部鍵かけっぱなしで隠れて一人で生活している老人もいますよ
誰も家に入れてくれない
で それもやっぱり財産がなくなるという
亡くなったら大変だっていう恐怖感なんですね
まあもっと単純に言えば
触れられることやらね
結婚できないこととか
そんなものも人間が自分の苦しみだと
不幸の原因だと言ってるし
まあ若い人だったら誰かに触れられると
これ結構ショックになるしね
で また離婚もまあ苦しみでしょうし
また相手に先に立たれることも
まあそれで苦しんでる人々もいますね
で まあ一緒にいたんですけど
先に亡くなられたんだと
これでショックを受けたりする
大体そういう人々の人生について聞いてみれば
まあうちの旦那がね 早くしなかったんだから
自分が苦しんでいると
そうでなければこんな苦しみじゃないんだぞって
それは大体その程度ですよ
で 私たち考えている苦しみっていうのは
まあどうったことないんですよ
仏教から見れば あんた方はそんなもんですかと考えているのはという態度なんだから
これが私たち一般の人々から見れば
もうとてつもない不幸なんですね
それ一つもあって欲しくないんですよ
こんなものにそっち出会うんだったら
もう生きる意味もないんだよと
自殺までする 例えば会社にリストラになったら自殺する人がいるでしょうし
仕事を亡くなっただけで自殺する人がいるでしょうし
誰かに触れられただけで自殺する人がいるでしょうし
もうみんなに仲良くみんな仲良くしてくれなかったと
ちょっとからかわれたと
いじめられたと それだけのことを自殺する人もいるでしょうに
だから一般人にとってはもうとてつもない苦しみなんですよ
仏教はなんだ そんな程度かという態度なんですけど
何であんた方そんな程度ですかと
で 一般仏教の物語を聞くと
例えば一番の社会人として成功することは絶対的な幸福でしょ
我々にとってはお釈迦様はそんなのは捨てちゃえと
出家しなさいというふうな元気な人々に元気じゃない人には言わないんです
すごい精神的に元気があって
頭も鋭い 人々だったら
あんたそんなくだらんことやらんでもいいやと
全部捨てなさいと ということだから
あんまり相手にしてない
社会的な成功っていうのは
他のことにしたってもね
まあ同じく 例えばまあ落第したり
うまくいかなかったりね
またやり直せばいいでしょうに
どうってことないでしょうと
リストラになったら何か探してそれで食べていればいいんだから
別に 何でもいいんだから
食べればいいんだからね
それで生きていられますよ
だから仏教だったら そんなこと言ったらすごい単純に失業になったら
だったらそこら辺にある何でもいいんだから
何か探してやりなさいと言ったら
何か私に 私はそんなこと言ったら何がやられるのかというと
今までこれぐらい給料もらっていたんではないかと
だから同じ給料を狙ってるんだから
何のためかというと やっぱり自分の社会的な立場とか
いろんなことをくだらないことを考えているんですね
そういうくだらんことを考えるんだから
もう人生はもう大変苦労になっちゃう
仏教はもうすごい簡単に見ている
例えば周りの人がうまく付き合えなかったら
一人でいればいいでしょう
うまく付き合う方法がわからなかったら
一人でいればいいんだから
別に答えがあるんですよ
この財産なんかなくなることは苦になるっていうのは
それはもう それは仏教はあまり気にしないんですよ
1文もなくたって もう別にへっちゃらやと
なぜかというとね 生まれた時も 1 文を持って生まれたわけじゃないでしょうに
それでこちらでいろんなことをして
何とかもう食べられるぐらいの財産ついてくるし
だったらある一定の財産がなくなっちゃっても
誰が気にするもんかと
また動けばまたそれなりに生きていられるんだと
自分の業があるんだからね
死ぬまで死ぬまで食べていられるぐらいの業がついてますよ
だから ある一定の一定の財産がなくなっても
それにしがみついて悩む人っていうのは全部なくなっちゃいます
だから仏教はすごい軽々とそういう問題見るんですよ
そういうことだから しかし
はっきりしてほしいんです
普通はこんなものを私にでも軽々く言うんだから
かなり批判されているでしょうに
すごく人を馬鹿にしているんだとかね
で 仏教立場はそんな立場なんです
なんだ それっぽっちかという
そうすると あんた方はそんな苦労に出会ってないんだから
そうやって軽々く言うんですけど
そのひどい目に遭った人の立場になってみたらとかね
と言われる場合もありますよ
とは言われませんよと
私 私個人したっても いろんなことに出会ったんですけど
全然もうへっちゃらで
すぐ乗り越えちゃいます
これだったらもうどうにもならんという
どんな問題に出会っても
なんだこれっぽっちがっていう感じで
なんとか乗り越えちゃう
乗り越えたって別にどうということでもないんですよ
だからまあやればできる話ですよ
で まあそういうことで
まずこのこの話の 1 番目の項目はそれ
私たちは苦しい 苦しいというものは
仏教はそれほど気にしていないということ
です またリストありますね
他人ほど美しくないこと
能力ないこと そんなくだらんことで苦しみますよ
もう男の場合はね もう体力のことですけどね
もう同じクラスだったらね
あいつはよく走れるんだとかね
よく野球できるできるんだとかね
女の人の場合はもう体の形やらね
皮膚の色やら目の透けてるところやら
鼻の形やらね そんなものにえらい苦しんでるんですよ
その程度なんですよ 他人ほど美しくないとかね
あるいは能力ないとかね
あの人はすごく英語できるんだけど
私にしてみれば で それで悩んじゃうんです
そこでいろいろ障害あることね
まあわかりやすく言っても
だいたい日本でよくあることはアトピーでしょうし
アトピーやら何か障害があると
これで悩むんですよ そんなのはどうということないんですよ
別に アトピーで生まれたら
その人は生まれた時からアトピーだから
別にそれ悩む必要ないでしょうに
例えば卵を食べられないんだと
食べなきゃいいっていうぐらいのことで
それで別に悩むことあるんですかね
例えば魚を食べると問題が起こると
それだったら小さい時も母親か誰かそれ発見するでしょ
それっきり魚食べさせませんだから別に悩むこともないでしょうね
ああ おいしい魚食いてえとかね
あれおいしいだろうとかね
食ったこともないんだから
それで食べたことないものっていうのは
突然食べてもおいしくないんですよ
しかし 人間がそれぐらいのことですごく悩む
あまりにも無知で 例えば日本の社会でちょっとした障害があると
まあ差別されることっていうのはひどいでしょうに
それで社会から差別されると
その人もそれで悩んだりする
差別する側も結構気分悪いんだからね
例えばこの人はなんだ
この体の形とかね 気持ち悪いと思っちゃうと気持ち悪いのは誰ですかね
言われる人でしょ 言われる人ではない
言う人でしょ だから あまりも愚かさで苦しむんですよ
例えば私はどこかへ行くとします
そこで目が見えない もうよだれいっぱいたらたら垂らしている大人に出会います
障害がありまして 目は見えないだけではなくて
ずっとまあ垂らしていると
よだれを これ 子供がよだれを垂らしたって別に気持ち悪くはないんですけどね
大人の場合 それでなんて気持ち悪い人ですかと私が思ったら
誰の痛みですかね それは
と思った人の苦しみでしょうに
痛みでしょうに だから人間っていうのは
ちょっと差が見えただけで
平気でその人を差別して
それでまあ自業自得ですごく苦しむんですよ
それでそう言われやられると
ちょっとした障害を持って生まれた人々も
世界を見て ああ やっぱり私にはあれが欠けている
これが欠けているとかね
それで悩んでる 例えば目が見えないと
やっぱり私に目が見えないんだからとかね
目が見えてほしいとか思うこと自体バカバカらしいんですよ
生まれつき見たことがないんだから
どうったことないと思いますけど
だから他人の話に乗せられちゃうと
そういう状態が欲しくなって
それで苦しんじゃうんですよ
本当に考えてみると 生まれた時も
例えば聴覚障害あるとしますね
そうすると音なんか聞いたことがないでしょうに
だから私も少し音楽を聴きたいんだとかね
思っちゃうと それからまた大変な苦しみ
私は障害者 障害者とかね
言い張ったりして そんなの何のこともないんですよ
聴覚の障害者だったら
音楽やら音やら聞いたことがないんだから
別に苦でも楽でもなんでもないんですよ
そこであの耳が見え 聞こえない人々にも音楽を演奏に参加してもらいますよと言って
なんか日本でなんかあちこちでいろいろ超くだらんことをやってるんです
手話で音楽を聴かせてあげてるんです
あれはバカなこと世の中あるかどうかわからないんですけど
どうやって手話で音楽を
演奏とかに ただ余計なことですよ
まあ耳が聞こえなかったらもう無言のドラマでも見れば
大体音あるドラマよりは無言のドラマは面白いですよ
無声映画とかね はっきりとそれを作らないとね
伝わりませんだから だからまあそういう人間で
そういう余計なことで苦しむ
それで競争し 競争で負けたこと
そっちを苦しむでしょ
そういうことで で 周りが自分の言うことを聞かないという
これも巨大な悩みなんですよ
特に親たちがね 子供はどんどん成長すると
それからすっごく悩むんですね
反抗期になってくると
親の神経なんかはすり減らすぐらい悩むんで
どうってこと聞かなきゃって放っておけばいいし
それできんですね 会社にしたって
私は上司なのに部下は言うこと聞かないんだよと
で まあそういうことですごく悩む
僕はどうしても言うことを聞かないで仕事をうまくしないんだったら
まあクビにしちゃえばいいでしょうし
私の命令に従って仕事できんだったら
やらんだったら出ていけと
荷物はいらんと まあそれだけど
それが自分があまり社長じゃないんだからできなかったならば
まあその人のレポートを書く場合は書きたい放題書いてやれば
この人は会社に対してはもう完璧なもうもう迷惑やと
全くもう生産能力はないんだとか何とか書いちゃえばなんとかなるでしょうね
まあそれはどちらかはっきりわかりませんだけど
部下がバカで上司がバカで部下が頭がよく場合でも
話言うこと聞かない時もありますけど
まあとにかく自分の言うことが聞けないということも
人間にとっては大変な悩みで
次にやるのは仕事がうまくはかどらないというね
で まあそんな悩みもあるし
対人関係 自信がない もう対人関係で苦しんでるんだとかね
ストレス溜まってるんだとかね
で やりたい仕事が見つからないという悩みも
大体若者の間でよくあるんですね
それでずっと仕事をなくて苦しんでるんです
なんで仕事をしないのか
やりたい仕事を見つからないんだと
私から私に言えば まず何でもいいんだからやってみなさいと
仕事なしなのでやりたい仕事を見つからないんだと
仕事したことがない人はどうやってやりたい仕事っていうのは考えられますかね
だからそれぐらいのことでみんな悩んでいる
一応それはそこら辺で
俗世間が考える苦しみ
悩み 決して無視できないんだと
こんなものに出会ったら大変不幸だとと思う悩みのリストなんです
私たちが考える怯える苦しみ
しかし 理性と工夫さえあれば
これらの苦しみはそれほど苦悩
苦悩の原因にならないのです
ほんのちょっとの工夫で
もう何のこともないんですよ
そんなの それは一つのポイント
だから今 ほんのちょっとの工夫
私も説明しましたからね
ほんのちょっとの工夫を説明します
例えば試験が落第しましたと
もう一度やればいいぐらいのことで
やっぱりもう一度やったでも落第するんだったら
別なことをやればいいんですよ
別な学校受かる学問変えるとかね
何でもいいんだから 別に
理科系にチャレンジしたところでうまくいかなかったと
だったら文科系にチャレンジする
それもうまくいかなかったら
どれだったらいろいろ職業専門学校とかあるで
そちらに行けばいいでしょうに
大学行ったよりは勉強もできますし
だからどうということではない
だからちょっと変えればなんとか解決方法があります
それで 2番目に書いてあるのは
もうちょっと別なことなんですよ
返り見ると この句は悪くないかもしれません
この我々一般人が苦しい苦しいと考えている苦しみっていうのは
よくよく見ると本当なのかという
もしかすると悪くないかもしれません
他人と全く同一になることはありえない
で たと差異があった方が良いのではないですか
結局それでしょう みんなに歌えるんだったら
誰がお金払って音楽買うんですかね
そうするとお金 音楽は商売にならないんですよ
世の中に生まれる人間
みんなに上手に絵を描く
絵を描ける そうすると絵描きさんにはもう商売ないんですよ
誰も買わない 自分好きなのを自分で書けますから
と だからみんななんであの人と同じくなりたい
あの人と同じくなりたいと思うんですかね
そうしちゃうと生きていられないんでしょうに
だから一人一人が才があること
違うということこそが
世の中をうまくいってますよ
音痴な人がいて すごく音程がいい人がいて
それで音程がいい人の音を聞いて
音痴な人はお金払う 音痴な人は絵は書ける
その人は絵を描いて 歌える人に売ってお金もらうと
そういうことで世の中成り立ってるんだから
そんなのはね 俗世間で考える苦っていうのは一つの苦じゃないんです
そこでも考え方は少し変えてみた方がいいんじゃないかなと
いわゆるどう生かせるかと
例えば障害を持って生まれると
この障害はどう生かせるかと
という見るだけのことなんですよ
だから逆に逆説で言えばね
自分の能力を生かせるんじゃなくて
自分の欠点を生かしちゃえばいいんです
自分が悩んでる私にはこれ
これも問題あり こういう問題ありとかね
それを生かしちゃえばいいんです
まあ例えば対人関係がうまくいかないんだと
人間と付き合っちゃうとひどいイライラするんだと
神経質になるんだと だったら
その人は全く人間との関係は成り立たない
仕事を見つければ 他の人々嫌がる仕事ありますよ
そのいろんなこの文書整理とかね
今まであるでしょう コンピューターいろいろ使って
もうくだらない いろいろあらゆる文書整理とかね
データの整理とか そんなのやればいいんですよ
じっと自分の部屋にもう職場でこれをドアも閉めて
ずっと朝から晩まで誰とも喋ることになる
そうすると社会の役に立ちますよ
それに元気な遊び回りたい人がその机に座らせちゃうと
そいつは仕事してくれないんですよ
あー嫌だ嫌だとかね コーヒー飲みたいとか
タバコ 1本吸いたいとか
逃げちゃうんですよ いつでも
それで仕事終わった まだです
まだですとかね それで対人関係はまるっきりできん人にそういう仕事を頼むと
もうもう上から全部資料
ファイルなんかドーンドーンと持っていくだけでしょうに
はい これもやりなさい
これもやりなさい これもやりなさいと
その人はどんどんファイルがたくさんだと喜ぶんですよ
あ これで結構仕事あるんだからいいんだと
だから自分の能力を生かすんじゃなくて
自分のああいう欠点を生かしちゃえばね
うまくいきます そういうことですから
この考え方を変えた方が簡単に乗り越えられる苦しみなんですよ
しかし この事実を認めない
会社の基準に乗せられて同一になろうとする
社会のね 私はこんな話したっても
私はただ無責任で冗談を言うと思ってるでしょ？あまりも単純だから冗談で言うんですよ
こんな真剣に言うほどもない
世界を良くするっていうことは
子供の遊びみたいなもんなんで
だから冗談で言いますけどね
しかし 人間っていうのは本当かと認めないんですよ
決定生かしちゃえばって
何言うんですかと あなたはと
アホじゃないかと 人間っていうのは才能を生かすんじゃないかとと思うでしょうに
才能を生かしてもいいんだけど
才能はある それはあるとするならばでしょうに
見いだせる才能っていうのはひとかけらもないんだから
もうどうにもならんでしょ
才能なければもう決定生かせる
そんなふうなことで  そういうことで
我々は社会の基準に乗ろうとするんですよ
だから我々にも限りない苦しみがある
その限りない苦しみは
仏教はなんだ その程度かということでもうあまり気にしない
はい それでもうちょっとこれはもう雑談ですけど
これ関係ないかもしれませんだけど
そこで我々は見事に騙されてるんですよ
社会の成功 職業の成功
金持ちになることとかね
それからちゃんと試験受かることやら
それこそ人生の幸福だとえらい勘違いしていて
それで人間がそれをうまくいかないと宗教に走るんですよ
お祈りでもして 自分が人生成功してやるんだぞと
特に日本みたいな社会の宗教観というのは九十九パーセント現世利益なんですよ
これ現世利益ってくだらんことを目指しているんですよ
お祈りしたくてもしなくても得られるんですよ
商売繁盛やら学問上手なんとか何とかとかね
そんなのはお祈りしなくてもいとも簡単に身につきますよ
それ下手だからお祈りするわ
いろんなことをする それで信仰にね
現世利益の目的だけの信仰に走ることもその原因なんですね
宗教が現世利益のみを強調するのは
それで宗教を説いてるバカたちも
もうただ何か喋ってるだけで真理わかってないでしょうに
もうなぜかというと 世の中で
まあ商売として言えばすごい楽な商売でしょうに
投資しなくても儲かるんだから
それでもういんちきな人々はもう詐欺やったっても
いろいろ法律で裁かれるし
では何か宗教でも作るではないかなといって
あっちこっち宗教作るんですよ
そこでも薬は飲まなくてもいいんだ
私はお祈りして治してあげるんだぞとかね
私はもう仏の言葉を聞いてあなた方に言ってるんではないかとか
まあ仏の言葉を聞く人はいるわ
神の言葉を聞く人はいるわ
もうハンドパワーで病気治したりする人はいるわ
それで除霊していろんなことをして商売繁盛してくれる宗教
もういっぱいくさんありますよ
とにかく宗教の側も人間に大事なことを教えるのではなくて
現世利益だけを謳っているんですね
だからどちらでも騙されているんですよ
どうったことない苦はものすごいとてつもない苦だと勘違いしているんです
凡人が怯えているような苦しみしか存在しないと思っているからではないでしょうか
だからそれ  そんなもので
ですから この世の中 どう見たても一向に良くなりっこはないんですよ
誰かの 例えば宗教やら精神的なところで何かアドバイスを受けしたっても
そういう現世利益 ご利益のことを喋ったりする
する 知識のある人だったらね
現世利益ぐらいは私は一人でやりますと
仕事もありますから 能力もありますから
商売ぐらい私は一人でやりますから
もっといい人間になることを教えてくれというふうに頼まなくちゃいけないんですよ
でも現代人はね 宗教に行って何聞くんですかというと
どうすれば商売繁盛するかってことを言っちゃうんです
次に仏教の世界 凡人は気にしないが
仏教は強調する 苦しみ
そこからつまらないと思いますよ
全然気にしないんだから
これから仏教の世界 パーリ語で書いてますけど
ジャーティ ジャラー ヴィヤーディ
マラナという 4つあります
苦しみ ジャーティっていうのは生まれること
ジャラっていうのは老いること
ヴィヤーディっていうのは病気になること
マラナっていうのは死
死ぬことですね それワンセット
苦しみの これが勉強できてもできなくても襲ってきますよ
リストラになってもならなくても
これが襲ってきます これはもう命の問題ですね
１番目は  ２番目 憂い 悲しみ
悩み 苦痛 落ち込みなど
それは精神的なものなんですね
これには差がありますよ
例えば まああんまり憂いがない
悲しみもない 落ち込まない人々もいますけど
程度の差があるんだけど
問題は ちょっと考えましょう
例えば病気取りましょう
病気で苦しむんだぞと言ってもリミットがあるんですよ
例えば風邪が引いて熱が出て
えらい苦しいんだと しかし
風邪を引いて熱が出て
その苦しみっていうのはリミットがあるんですよ
これ以上は苦しみないんだぞと
お腹が壊したならば お腹が壊したという苦しみだけで限界があるんですよ
それ以上は苦痛は生まれません
それよく覚えておいてください
この体の苦しみっていうのは
無限に限りなくあるわけじゃないんですよ
例えば足 足に誰かが殴ったら痛いんですよ
また殴ったらもっと痛いんですよ
そうすると回 ４回 １０
回殴ると１０倍痛いでしょ
そうすると１万回殴ったら１万回痛いと思いますか？痛くないんです
リミットを超えたらもうわからなくなっちゃうんです
だから体の痛みにはこれというリミットがあるんです
それで この ２番目に書いている
この憂い 悲しみ 悩みという精神的な悩みの場合は
いつでもそのその人によって量の大きさが大小ありますよ
あるんだけど こちらにはリミットがないんですよ
一歩間違えばどこまででも苦しみが増えるんですよ
これは一番怖いんです
このがんになるとかね
そんなどうってことないんですよ
がんになって苦しいとしたっても
リミットがあるんだからね
それ以上は苦しみはないんですよ
でも悩んだりするとどこまででも悩めるんです
悲しくなろうとしちゃうと
どこまででも悲しくなるんです
頭が狂ってしまうところまで
ものすごい怖いんです
この ２番目の問題は そこでまあ
まあそこそこのことで
好きな人を好きなものから別れる
別れで 嫌な人 嫌なものとは付き合うこととかね
で これが生きている限りは誰にも避けられない事実なんです
で これもあって  4番目は執着すべき体と心があること自体
一番怖い苦しみやと いわゆるあんたいることが苦しみやということなの
わかりやすく言えば で
私に対して 私に対してはかわいい体があって
かわいい自分がいるんですよ
この可愛い体と可愛い自己というか
自分という感覚がある限りは
もうずっと苦しいもんですと
それが仏教がすごい強調する苦しみで
みんなに無視されちゃうんです
でも 悟ったお釈迦様は
これこそ本当の苦しみだと
はい そこでなんでそれがそんなに苦しみかというと
ブッダが解く苦しみは絶対的なものです
中途半端な苦しみじゃないんですよ
皆様 誰かに触れられたとかね
もう付き合い もう結婚していたのに
何でしたっけ 離婚されたとかね
そんなのは絶対的なものじゃないし
すぐ解決するもあるしね
でもこれがそんなもんじゃ絶対的なんです
たとえ差があるとしても
普遍的にすべての衆生を襲っているのです
少々の差がありますよ
たまたま病気にならない人もいるし
で まあ年は取ったっても元気で元気でね
いる人もいるし たまたま少々の差が見えますけど
例えば憂い 悲しみっていうのは強烈な人もあって
まあそれほどない人もいるんですけど
誰にでもあります そこで私はこちらでたとえ差があると書いたのは
その意味ではないんです
お釈迦様が天国に生まれ変わっても
この苦しみは絶対的ですと
という立場で語っているんです
大体一般的な皆様方はね
亡くなったら成仏できるだろうとかね
誰かが供養してくると
それで成仏できると簡単に思っているでしょう
でも成仏したっても この苦しみからはね
逃げられない 襲うんです
天国に生まれても 極楽道に生まれても
これが襲ってくる いる場所によってちょっと差がちょっと違う
野良犬とものすごい金のかかる
この何百万も値打ちのある犬とはね
生活はそれぞれ差がちょっと違いますけど
しかし 問題は絶対的にあります
気づいていないが 人間が考える苦も
この普遍的な苦から現れるのです
みんな我々気づいてないんですよ
例えば試験は失敗しましたと
それで悩んでいるんだと言っても
あの人 試験が失敗したんだから悩んでるわけじゃないんです
お釈迦様おっしゃった子から
あの悩みが生まれてるんですよ
期待は外れるんだよということはわかってないんです
だから苦しんでるんです
大体お釈迦様がおっしゃっている苦から
俗世間 凡人が考える苦が現れるのは二次的なものなんです
根本的な苦じゃないんです
で 常に襲われている この苦しみは第一に怯えるべきものです
本当に我々は怯えるべき苦しみは
今説明した苦しみなんて
もう言っちゃ元に戻してください
私たちはあまりにも怖くて怯えるべき苦しみはこの 4つなんです
病気になることやら死ぬことやら
いろんなものから別れたりしなくちゃいけないんだ
嫌なものと付き合わなくちゃいけないんだ
それだけじゃなくて もう体は可愛い体があるんだから
これがえらい迷惑だと
例えば肉体を可愛がってあげればあげるほど
恐ろしく苦しみが出てくるんですよ
栄養をあげなくちゃいけないんだとかね
それまた何でしたっけ？有機栽培の食べ物はあげなくてはいけないんだとかね
体が可愛ければ可愛いほど
もう 100円で買えるものは
自分が探し買う場合  1,000円になったりもしますよ
だからまあ これが本当に我々を脅かしている一番恐ろしい苦しみだと理解しなくてはいけないんですよ
ん？ちょっと飛び出た
ちょっと待って はいはい
はい これから まあこれは序文で
これから今日のテーマで
で 聖者と凡人の苦しみ方
これはサンユッタニカーの 4番目のテキスト
ローマ字版でね  207ページにあります
それと経典の名前はサッラッテーナという名前なんです
サッラッテーナという意味は
矢に刺されてという いわゆる矢に刺されてはどうすればというふうな意味で
パーリ語だったらね サッラッテーナ
それ そういうタイトルなんですね
うん これからは簡単です
で 矢に刺されて気になるのは苦だけでは
苦は避けたいが 楽なら何でも良い生き方
これが我々の生き方なんですよ
私たちは苦だったら絶対嫌ですよ
もう避けたくてたまらんです
しかし 楽だったらもう何でも来い
何でも来いという まあ俗っぽく言えば
お金だったらいくらでもいいやというふうな生き方なんですね
だから我々は苦を避けたい
避けたいと必死 しかし
楽だったらすっと出てこい出てこい出てこいという生き方をしている
人間に苦楽 不苦不楽という 3つの感じ方があるのに
人間に感じ方は 3つあるんですよ
感覚は 苦もあって楽もあって
不苦不楽という中立的な感覚があるのに
無視する 1本だけ 3分の1だけに引っかかるんですよ
苦を避けようとして怒りに苦しむ
そこで苦しんでくると
もう避けよう 避けよう
なくそう 攻撃しようとかね
嫌やと思って人間がものすごく怒るんですよ
それで苦しむんです 楽のみを期待して欲で悩む
そこで頭の中で楽をしたい
楽をしたい 楽しみたい
そればっかり考えてるんです
それで期待で 期待で 希望で
いろんなことで激しく悩むことになります
欲で  3番目 不苦不楽を無視して無知と退屈感で悩む
人生は楽でもなければ苦でもないという状態になってくると
えらい退屈なんですよ
そこで力がもうなくなって
無気力になって もう無知で無知で
もうまた激しく悩むことになるんです
素晴らしいことというのは
人間は苦に出会っても悩む
楽に出会っても悩む 苦でもない
楽でもない中立的な感覚であっても
思い存分悩むんですよ
頭がいいんですよ 人間幸せにしてあげれば何すればいいかと
どんな感覚を与えたっても
見事にそれは悩みの結果にするんです
これは人間の生き方なんです
すべてただの感覚です
これからもう ちょっとこの説明しなくちゃいけない
このお釈迦様っていうのは
あまりこの現象的なことでは喋りません
私は日本で説法を始めた時から
ずっと私に言われたのは
すごく具体的に教えてくれと
私はずっとそれはもうもうごまかしちゃうんですよ
具体的にっていうのは
ある人がうちの娘は云々やらと言って
その場合はどうすればいいかと
それを教えたら また次の別な人が来て
うちの息子はとまた始まるんです
それで一人にうちの娘はなんとかなんとか言ったところで
それ聞いた人が自分に合うように
そのアドバイスをね 改良しようとしない
それは私に関係ないんだ
私の息子の問題は唯一の問題で
世界でこれしか問題ないんだよというふうに出てくるんです
だから 夫婦関係がうまくいかないんだとかね
例えば旦那が不倫するんだそうとアドバイスを受けた場合でも
各女性が自分だけ特別
自分だけでこれで悩んでる特別な問題だと思ってるんですね
だから一般的なアドバイスは嫌やと
私だけにアドバイスしてください
そんなことというのはやりきれんでしょうに
例えば 息子は 10歳で何か問題を起こしたら
うちの息子は今 10歳なんですけど
今こういうトラブルってますよと
それで教えてあげる また
うちのうちの息子は今 11歳だけど
またあの問題は今ないんだけど
今こういうことをしているんだよと
それに教えたら うちの息子は今 12歳だけど
今前のアドバイス受けてうまくいったんだけど
今は別なことをやってるんだよ
どこまで言うんですかね
私は それはあまりにも無知な怠けな人々のやり方なんですよ
物事は根こそぎに取らなくちゃいけないんですよ
心理全部全体的に把握しなくちゃいけないんですよ
例えば ある女の人がカーネーションの花をあげるとすごく喜ぶんだよと
いうことを何でもやってくれるんだよと言って
それ勉強したっても何の役にも立ちませんよ
なぜならば ある特定のその女だけですから
カーネーションもらったら喜んで舞い上がっちゃって乗ってしまうのは
だからそういうふうに
この具体的なアドバイスというのは役に立ちません
聞きたがる気持ちはわかりますけど
それで私もそれけちつけますけど
それはこの早々接する怠けなんです
自分自身で物事を考えてこないんですよ
えらいつまらないと思いますよ
物事を面白く いろんなものを考えると面白いんですよ
こういうことはこうなってるんだから
こういうふうにこうなるんではないかとかね
いわゆるいろんなインスピレーション的に
あのクリエイティブというね
クリエイティブシンキングっていうのは面白いんですよ
これがまるっきりない場合は
もうどうすればいいんですかね
どうすればいいんですかね
ずっと聞きっぱなしで
仏教の世界はまあまあ相談はしたってもいいんだけど
できるだけ自分で解決法を考えた方が
いいんですよ そこで例えば誰かが問題に出会って
うまくそれを乗り越えたら
私はすごく楽しいんですよ
日本でも知ってる何人かの間でとてつもないトラブルに出会って
それで自分でまた乗り越えて
それを私は電話で言うんですよ
こういうことになって
私はこういうこういうことをしてうまく乗り越えたんだよと
言うと 私にとってそれほど楽しいことはないんですよ
やっぱりこの人 私にアドバイス
私のアドバイスも何も聞かないで
しっかりと自分一人で頑張ったと
もう人はできているんだと
自分の努力は無駄ではなかったと
で そっちを話聞くとね
あれがすごい苦しいんですよ
うるさいし 時間はないし
役に立たないし 時々したアドバイスは
日にち経ったらまた賞味期限切れちゃうんですよ
この具体的なアドバイスもそんなもんですよ
例えば息子とすごい喧嘩して
こちらに来て 私のアドバイス受けて
じゃあこうしましょうって言っても
息子はもう感じが変わっちゃって
あるいはどこかへ友達と遊びに行って帰っている
気分がいいんだと そうすると
あのアドバイスは効かないでしょうに
通じないんです だから具体的なアドバイスというのは
いつでも生ものですよ
すぐその場で使わなきゃ
もう 役に立たない だからブッダの教えっていうのは
1 日で腐る豆腐みたいな教えじゃないんです
皆様が聞きたがるのはそれなんです
豆腐くれと 永遠な命 それでもらいましょうと
豆腐をあげたっても それで食っちゃえばそれで終わりますけど
だけど お釈迦様がアドバイスっていうのは
このどんな時代でも価値のあるダイヤのようなもの
宝石のようなものなんですね
人間での原始時代でも
宝石やら金やらありがたがっていたんですよ
今この古い墓とか掘ったりすると見つかるでしょうに
だから遠い昔も宝石やら金やら価値がありました
今も価値がある これからも価値があるんですよ
だから普遍的な価値がないと教えではないんです
そこで仏教の特色 それよく覚えてください
私たちの機嫌を取るために喋っているわけじゃなくて
この宝石ダイヤを与えてくれるんです
豆腐一丁くれるわけじゃないんです
冷やっこ食べたいと思っている人には
さっと冷やっこ豆腐一丁あげることは
その人は瞬時に喜びますけど
それで終わるんですよ
でも その人には大財産をあげれば
消えない財産をあげれば
豆腐一丁食いたければ豆腐一丁も食べられるし
お風呂いっぱい豆腐入れて
その中に入り込んで寝なければ寝かければそれもできるし
豆腐は体にもいいんだよと
美容にもいいんだよと言って
バスタブいっぱい豆腐でいっぱいにしてその中に入っているとかね
それでもできるでしょうに
別に 財産さえあれば だから仏教っていうのはそういう特色なの
いつでも論理的なところ
理論を教えてあげる そうするとすべて早く幸せになります
それで 人生を正しく論理的に見るならば
苦・楽・不苦不楽という三つとも同格で観察する
それでいきなり仏教はあんた幸せですか？とかね
神様は信じていますか？とかそんな話は聞かない
そうじゃなくて あなたは三つ感じているんだと
楽しみ 苦しみ どちらでもない感覚
生まれた瞬間から死ぬ時まで
生まれ変わったらまたそれで輪廻転生する限りは
神であろうか 鬼であろうか
人間であろうか 餓鬼であろうか
霊であろうが関係ないんだよと
動物であろうか みんな三つの感覚を感じている
ですから 私の人生幸せですかと聞いたとしても
答えがないはずなんですよ
私の人生は不幸で苦しいですかと言ったって
なぜかというと 凡人のレベルで苦もあって楽もあって
不幸不楽もあるんだから
これを評価しないと正しく
ただ苦だけ見て人生は苦しいと言っても正しくないし
ちょっと楽しかったことだけ覚えておいて
私は幸せもんだと言ったってもバカバカらしいし
ちょっと不幸不苦不楽の感覚で
私は本当に退屈で人生はつまらないんだと言ってもバカバカらしいんですよ
たとえ 1分の１分の間でも
いろんな苦 楽 不苦不楽
ざらざらざらざらざらざらと生まれてくるんですよ
ちょっと体観察してみてください
今座っていらっしゃるでしょうに
では お尻の感覚は何ですかね
苦しい 楽 それ変わるんですよ
時々楽に感じる 時々苦で感じる
時々どうったこともなく感じる
だから一概に言ってはいけません
あ この椅子は楽ちんやとかね
そうはありえないんです
だから仏教っていうのは
そういう論理的に すごい客観的に
同格で見てほしいんです
苦も楽も 不苦不楽も 次に
この 3つとは体と心の感覚です
この苦楽 あるいは中立的な感覚
いわゆる不苦不楽っていうものは体と心の感覚なんですよ
しかし 正しく言えば 体は心なしでは何も感じないので
私の体から心が抜けちゃうとただの物体ですからね
何も感じません ので 心の特色ですよ
この感覚っていうのは
ここで皆様がまだまだ乗っているか
話に乗っていないかわかりませんだけど
私は苦しみか楽しいかということは今変えたんですよ
感覚という言葉に 感覚言えば科学的な言葉なんですよ
あの人幸せだっていうことは科学的じゃないんです
感情的な なんかいい加減な言葉なんです
評価も何もできない しかし
その人の感覚でいえば
医学的にも評価できる
科学的なんです ですから
仏教はあなたは幸せですか？不幸ですか？ではなくて
あなたの感覚はいかがなものでしょうかというところから話始まるんです
論理的に だから これからの話は全部感覚ですよ
そういうことだから 感覚で言ったっても心なんですよ
例えば人に殴られて あ
気持ちいいという場合もあるでしょ
人に殴られたら必ずしも痛いということはないんですよ
で 気持ちいい時もあります
犬に噛まれたらいつでも怖いと思いますかね
時々飼っている犬がふざけて遊ぶと結構噛むんですよ
手やら足やらもうもう鼻やら耳やらもう好きなところ
ちゃんと噛みますけど
その時は別に痛い痛いとかなんて思いませんでしょうね
だから犬に噛まれたらそれは怖いぞという風なことは言えませんしね
だから感覚のことで判断する
心の状況で判断する 自分が飼っている犬がもうかわいい犬が遊びながら手を噛んだりして
その時も痛みがあるんですけど
別に苦痛や不幸や怖いだ
苦しいんだとは思わない
心の状態なんですよ 同じことを隣の家の犬がやっちゃうと
これ大変なことになるんです
だからやっぱり苦も楽も
不苦不楽も 幸せも不幸も心の問題なんです
具体的なものではありません
具体的に存在することでもない
これは仏教ではヴェーダナ
感受性という専門用語を使っています
これが生命の起源であって
この我労が私がいるんだぞという誤解も
このヴェーダナから 感覚から生まれるんですよ
だから仏教の説明の中心点はこのヴェーダナなんです
ヴェーダナを発見して悟れるんです
では ちょっと休憩しましょうか
それではヴェーダナという感覚
体で感じる感覚といっても
心で感じる感覚ですけど
それから進めてみます
じゃあ次いきます そこでなんで感覚ということで
これは説明しましたけどね
一時的な現象を理解しても
ある側面だけ気になって勉強しても
物事をわかったことにはなりません
やっぱり論理的に理解しないと
一時的なものを勉強しなくてもいいと
物事の根本原理を理解すると
すべてをわかったと言えるのです
ブッダは苦に対して一時的な現象ではなく
普遍的な原理を教えられたのです
ですから 私たちは気分はわかりますけどもね
まあ夫婦喧嘩どうしましょうか
そういう具体的なことを知りたがりますけど
それだったらね これ一時的な現象
やっぱり普遍的なことを語らなくちゃいけない
もう確かにお釈迦様はすごい具体的に喋りましたけど
仏教は未だに生きているのはこの普遍的なことを語っておいたんだからなんです
だから我々は今も使って
将来的にもブッダの教えは使えるんですよ
例えば  Aさんと Bさんの喧嘩についてお釈迦様が語ったならば
それは Aさんと Bさんと生きている間のだけの話で
そういうことで このあまり今日の現象的なことは置いておいて
原理での立場で喋ります
はい 次に行きます それで凡人の感覚
これから矢に刺されてという経典を続けていきます
それで苦はヴェーダナ
感覚として解き明かすのです
お釈迦様は苦っていうことはヴェーダナという言葉に入れ替えるんです
そこで経典でこういう風な言葉が出てきます
アッスタワビッカウェプトゥッジャノ
スカンピヴェーダナヴェーディヤティ
ドゥッカンピヴェーダナヴェーディヤティ
アドゥッカマスカンピヴェーダナヴェーディヤティ
すごいわかりやすく言うんです
アッスタワというのは別居していない
物事考えない 考えていない
知識は浅い 知識のないビッカビクたちに呼びますから
プトゥッジャノ 凡人 一般の人々
一般人がスカンピヴェーダナ
楽の感覚も感じる ドゥッカンピヴェーダナ
あ がちょっと抜けてます
ドゥッカンピヴェーダナ
苦しみの感覚もヴェーディヤティ感じる
アドゥッカマスカン 不苦不楽
楽でもない 苦でもない感覚も感じますよ
まず設定します 知識のない一般人は苦も感じる
楽も感じる 不苦不楽も感じると
はい 次 で これは凡人の感覚
それで聖者の感覚といえば
スッタワビッカアリアサーワコ
スカンピヴェーダナヴェーディヤティ
ドゥッカンピヴェーダナヴェーディヤティ
アドゥッカマドゥッ...アドゥッカマスカンピヴェーダナヴェーディヤティ
なんでが抜けてますかね
まあこちらではちょっと打ち間違いでが入ります
えんとえの間いたり まあパーリ語を知っている人々だったら直してください
で 知識のある聖者の弟子
楽の感覚も感じる 苦の感覚も感じる
不苦不楽の感覚も感じるのである
なんかおかしいでしょ？凡人も楽は感じる
苦は感じる 不苦不楽感じる
聖者も楽は感じる 苦は感じる
不苦不楽感じる と はい
次 それで聖者の また間違いね
もう今日は朝も慌てて 10時ぐらいで始めたんだから
ギリギリで仕事しないんだから
聖者と凡夫の違いですね
タトラビクケコビソイソコアディッパアディッパヨソじゃね
アディッパヨソ タトラビクケコビソイソコアディッパヨソキンナーナーカラナン
ストートワリーサーヴァカッサストータプトゥッジャナイナティ
でお釈迦様は同じことを言い出しちゃって
凡人も空不空楽不空楽感じます
聖者も空不空楽感じます
それじゃ何が違いますかと
お釈迦様はまた聞くんです
で ここで聖者の弟子と知識のない凡人と差異
相違は何なのかと 何が違いますかと
とお釈迦様は質問するんですよ
で そこに書いてはないんですけど
それで お坊さんたちには答えられないでしょうね
そんなこと なんかわけのわからないことをお釈迦様が教えたんだから
それで比丘たちは まあ教えっていうのはお釈迦様とくものでしょうしと
その差っていうのは お釈迦様が教えるんであって
私たちはのお釈迦様から話を聞いて理解しますよと
ですから まあ教えてくださいと
違いは何なのかというお願いするんですね
そこから それでお釈迦様は説法始まるんです
まずたとえが来るんですよ
これがもう矢のたとえが出てくるところなんです
セイヤカービクウェ プリサンサッレーナヴィッジェッユン
タメナンデュティエーナサッレーナヴィッジェッユン
エワンエソービクウェプリソーデーサッレヴェーダナーヴェーディアティ
まあ今書いてると 日本訳は専門家の訳ではなくて
私はもう慌てて勝手に訳するものです
で 比丘たちよ 人が矢に刺されたとします
それから彼は2番目の矢にも刺されたとします
このように彼は2つの矢に刺された感覚を感じます
またそれだけのこと 人が矢に刺されたとしましょう 1
本の矢に刺されたところで
また2本目 2本目も来て当たると
これで2本の矢の苦しみを味わわなくてはいけないんだと
はい エヴァメーワコウビクウェアッスッタワープトゥッジャノドゥッカヴェーダナヤプットーサマーノソーチャティキラマティパリデーヴァティウラッターリンカンダティサッモーハンガーパッジャテ
ィ
これでエヴァメーワというのは
そのように知識のない凡人は苦悩感覚に触れた時
悲しむわ 悩むわ 嘆くわ
胸を叩きながら泣くわ
混乱に陥るわと もう切りがないんですよ
例えばちょっと階段ちょっと滑って
まあまあまあ腰が当たったとします
これ痛いんですよ 痛い 1
本の矢でしょうに それで終われないんですよ
まあ悲しむわ 泣くわ 嘆くわ
怒鳴る もう切りがないんです
これが2番目の矢なんです
単純なことでしょうに
だからまあそこできないんだと
はい ソーデーヴェーダナーヴェーディアティ
カーイカンチャチェータシカンチャ
彼は身体的と精神的という 2つの苦しみの感覚を感じるのです
何か不幸に出会ったら
これ嘆くは悲しむわ 悩むは文句言うはもう切りがないでしょう
そうするとお釈迦様は言うのは
その人は 2つの苦しみを味わっている
出会った不幸と それから精神的に自分で作り出す不幸という 2つで困りますと
はい そこでさらに問題は悪化する
まあむちゃくちゃにするんですよ
凡人は 例えば試験ぐらいは堕落しただけで十分ですよ
もう人生むちゃくちゃにしてしまって
もう殺人までするかもしれません
無差別殺人まで 凡人というのはそんなもんなんです
だからもう軽々と生きてみればいいということで
これでタッサーエワコウパナドゥッカーヤ
これあまりも間違ってます
これヴェーダナーへと直してください
ここヴェーダナーだから
タッサーエワコウパナドゥッカーヤヴェーダナーヤプットーサマーノパティガワーホーティ
それで苦しみに出会ったら
パティガワーホーティ
えらく怒るんですよ 大体誰でも不幸になっちゃうと気分悪いでしょうに
もうただ体に何か痛みにあったっても気分が悪いし
もうやったことを失敗しても気分が悪いし
リストラされても気分が悪いし
クビになっても気分が悪いんだから
これは気分が悪いってこと
怒りなんです 苦しみに出会ったら必ずしも怒る
タメナン ドゥッカ ヴェーダナ
パティガワンタン ヨー
ドゥッカ ヴェーダナ パティガアヌセヨアヌセティ
そこでもう次にこの怒りの人になっちゃうんですよ
まあ例えば人がちょっと事故を起こしたりしちゃうと喧嘩することになるでしょ
事故はどうったことないんだけど
これからもうカンカン怒って怒りに燃えちゃって
だから別な問題なんです
それからは 時々この車の世界であることで
ちょっと誰かちょっとクラクション鳴らしただけでも
車から降りてきて人を刺すとか
クラクション鳴らされただけだとちょっとうるさいかもしれません
それぐらいのことでもう殺されますよ
世の中は だからこの体で何か苦しみがあったところで
これ何とかすればいいし
痛み止めでも飲めば治るし
あるいはちょっと待てばね
この痛みが消えるでしょうに
骨が折ったってもね これ 1週間
2週間でもう治るでしょうに
例えば他人の不注意で私は滑って骨が折れたとします
それから私はその人に対して怒るんですね
自分の心残るんですよ
それから解決する問題は
この骨折の問題ではありません
かなりもう怒りに苦しんでいる
燃えている 恐ろしい人の問題を解決しなきゃいけない
瞬間 そこでこの怒った怒りに
怒った人がこの潜在煩悩を作るんですよ
この性質 怒りの性質を潜在させることになる
これが恐ろしい 怖いんですよ
だからそっちを怒ると
その怒りが心の中に沈んで沈んで沈んで
もうどうにもならないんですよ
もう もう一体化になっているんです
たとえお釈迦様が来たって
もう救えない状態になるんです
これが潜在煩悩というんです
パーリ語でアヌセーというんです
なんで瞑想させるのかというと
そのわけなんです もう心はもう役に立たない
汚れそのもの だから完全に横領しなきゃ
ということで瞑想しなきゃということで
とにかくちょっとしたことで
我々は潜在 潜在的にも心を汚しちゃうんですよ
で このそれで次にそう
ドゥッカ ヴェーダナ ブッダ様のカーマスカンガビナントキ
この馬鹿がそこで終わらないんですよ
そっちを苦しみに出会うと
ああ 楽しいこと欲しいなとかね
遊びたいなとか 例えばお腹を壊して病院にいると
何か病気で病院に行ったら
まあごちそう食べたいなとかね
病院の食べ物は食べられないんだとか言って
病院隠れて逃げちゃって
体に悪いものを食べてまた病気悪化することっていうのは
これまたある 人間っていうのは気に入らないものに出会うと
強烈に欲しくなるんですよ
気に入るもの ちょっとまずいものを 2回ぐらい食べると
もうごちそうを食べたくて食べたくてうずいているんです
そういうことだから 次にカームスク
欲 欲楽と私は書いたんですけど
まあただそのまま直訳しちゃったんです
欲楽という日本語はないんですけどね
で まあ漢訳では欲だけになっちゃいますけどね
とにかくもう遊びたくなるんです
苦しみに出会うと これでさらに問題が悪化する
はい 次に行きます 理由はタンキッサヘトゥ
ナヒビッカウェーパジャナティアストゥタワプトゥッジャノアンニャトラカームスカードゥッカールヴェーダナヤニッサラナ
お釈迦様はすごいけなしてるんです
私は丁寧に訳しましたけど
なぜでしょうか 欲楽以外
苦しみから解放させる方法はあると知らない
まあ直訳するともっときついんですよ
このアストゥタワプトゥッジャの何も勉強してない凡人ということ
バカっていうことでしょ
この愚か者は欲に溺れることしか知らないんだよと
この苦しみを乗り越える方法は
正しい方法はあるんですけど
こいつは知らないんだから
また欲に溺れるんだと
はい 次に ちょっと文章は長いんですけど
省略しています タッサカームスカンアビナンラント
ラーガンセヨアヌセティ
一つ煩悩に汚染されちゃって
全然潜在的にもういっぱいなのに
心は 苦しんで怒りで 次に何しますかというと
あれ欲しい これ欲しい
遊びたい ご飯食べたい
踊りたい 踊ら踊りたい
あれこれともう欲が頭がいっぱいになってくると
ラーガ 欲の性質がまた潜在することになります
もう一つ 煩悩が心の中に増えるんですよ
まあ心いっぱいなんですけど
もうぎゅうぎゅうと全部煩悩に詰まって置いておくんです
さらに問題は悪化になります
はい ソーターサンヴェーダナナンサムデアンチャアッタガマンチャアッサダンチャアディーナンチャニッサラナンジヤタブータンナッパジャナティ
これでお釈迦様の答えなんです
何かバカバカらしいのをそのまま受けるのではなくて
仏教はいつでも物事を分析しなさいよと言ってるんですよ
ですから 例えばたとえ苦しみに出会っても
このこれは考えなくちゃいけないんですね
1番目サムデヤン なんでこの苦しみが現れたんですかと
あ これでこれでやと簡単にわかるでしょうに
で すごい簡単で 例えば足が滑って
落ちた場合は腰が打ってしまってすごく痛くなるとしますね
それでくだらんことを考えるんじゃなくて
ただ腰が床に硬いものにぶつかった
触れた だからその場所は痛いと
それだけですよ もし足が滑っても
落ちたところはマットレスみたいなものだったら痛くはないんだからね
で そちらでガラスの破片でもあったならば
痛いだけではなくて もう怪我もしているだというぐらいのことで
この苦しみはどのように現れたかという正起ですね
それを見てない 見てほしいんです
それでこの苦しみはどうやって消えるかと
例えば腰が打っても 二度と打ちませんだからね
それから触れないでしょ
じわじわと消えるんです
痛くなっても まあ骨も折れたならば
まあまたそれもじわじわと消えます
だから原因で生まれて原因で消えていくんだということは
どのように消えるかで
それも見てほしい また定義いろいろありますよ
まあ一応省略します それから長所短所も見てほしいと
どんなものにも長所があって
短所もあります あらゆる現象にそれがあるんですよ
あらゆる現象に正気があって
滅があって 長所があって短所があります
それから解放というものもあります
いわゆる解決方法 どんなものからにも解決するという方法もあります
その ３つ  4つですね  5つ
仏教は何か見る場合は
この 5つの側面で見てほしいがあるんです
そういう風に見てほしいんだけど
この人はありのままに見ない
野尻さんに書いたのはありのままということで
ありのままにしてない
簡単単純なのに 例えば
なんとなく自分が気分が悪くなったと
なんでやと見たら音がうるさいと
それで音が触れるんだから気分が悪くなったと
それどうすればいいかと
音を消せばいいんです
音を消せば気分が悪くなったことが消えるんだよ
単純ですよ だからで 音っていうのは確実に悪いものというわけでもないんです
音にも長所 短所というものはあります
あの音は別な音になったら楽しいでしょうし
いろいろあるでしょうに
それでニッサラなき出すっていうのは
このまたちょっと立場が違う
私はうるさいと思ったのも
音に束縛されていたから
綺麗な音だなと思っても
音に束縛されていたんだと
束縛しないんだったら
この問題になりませんということは解放なんです
そういう風に どんなものにもこの 5つの立場で見るんです
この愚か者という無知の凡人がそういう風に見ない
すぐ当たる 痛いんではないか
何やるんですか？相手に当たっちゃうんです
はい これで終わらない
また煩悩を作るんですよ
そこで苦にあって楽を探す
もう見つかる場合も見つからない場合もあるし
省略していますけど アドッカマスパイウェディナアイージャンセヨアヌセティ
そこでこの苦も楽も間でこの不苦
不楽感覚も生まれますから
そこでその人はもう 彼は不幸
不楽の感覚に対して無明の性質を全裁する
もしかすると たった子供が遊んでいて
野球ボールが流れてきて
自分の体に当たったかもしれません
ただの子供の遊びだから
別にプロでもなんでもないんだからね
そんなのは痛くも痒くもないんですよ
まあしかし まあまあちょっとだけ痛いとかね
はあるかもしれません
ちょっと怖かったかもしれません
球が体に当たって それだけのことなんですけど
その時はます怒り怒る
子供に怒鳴るか怒鳴らないかは別として
怒るんですよ 確実に なんてことを
それで子供を見たら怒鳴れない状態だったら
自分がもう怒りに燃えるだけ止まっちゃうし
で それを覚えてるでしょ
そこで怒りが それで煩悩で繊細する
それと一緒にまたまあ楽なことを妄想する
ここら辺でいたら もうなんて言いますか
子供たち遊んでるところだから危険ですよと
ですから もっと気分がいいところに散歩をできればいいのにとか
川のそばに散歩をできればいいのにとか思ったりする
そうすると楽を目指してるんですね
そこら辺の花を見に花を見ながら
あの涼しい空気を体に触れながら
誰か誰かと会話しながら散歩をすることを期待するんですよ
それでまた欲にまた心が汚染されます
としたっても 苦しみの次に必ずしも楽しみが出てくるんじゃないんだから
幸福 不楽も間にあるんです
その時は無明という煩悩を繊細する
それでたった野球ボールが当たっただけなんですけど
その瞬間ででも頭の悪い人は結構煩悩を作ってしまうんです
心を汚してしまうんです
はい そう スカンチェ ウェーダナンウェーディアティサンニョットーナンウェーディアティ
だから一般人は 凡人というのは
彼は楽の感覚を感じる時
束縛されたままで感じるのです
おぼ...溺れて束縛されて
もう手も足も出ない状態で
出られない状態で楽を感じるんだと
はい ドッカンウェーダナンウェーディアティサンニョットーナンウェーディアティ
では苦しみを感じる時どうですかと言えば
やっぱり同じ 束縛されたままで苦しみを感じる
どうにもならない状態で感じるんですよ
はい 次 アドッカマスカンチェウェーダナンウェーディアティサンニョットーナンウェーディアティ
これで幸福・不楽の感覚が感じると思ったっても
束縛されたまんまで なぜならば無知だから
もうというか 凡夫だから
凡人だから 五つの立場で物事を見ていないんだからね
もうどうしようもないんですよ
束縛されているんです
はい それでお釈迦様の結論
アヤンブッチェティビッカヴェアッスッタワプトゥッジャノサンニョットージャーティアマラネーナ
ソーケーヒパリデーヴェーヒドゥッケーヒドーマナッセーヒウパヤーセーヒサンニョットードゥッカスマーティワダラティ
はい これの意味は これですよと
アヤンブッチェティこれですよと
比丘たちよ アッスッタワプトゥッジャノ
知識のない凡人が ジャーティマラネーナ
いわゆる輪廻から解放されてないんだよ
ジャーティっていうのは生まれること
マラナというのは死ぬこと
だから生死から解放されていない
それから悩み 悲しみ 憂い
苦しみ 苦痛 そういうものから解放されていない
一般人はずっと必ずしも精神的な悩みは付いてるんです
解放された だから一般人は必ずしも 2番目の矢にやられるんです
これが 2番目の矢なんです
次は 知識のない凡人は
生まれること 死ぬこと
悲しみ 嘆き 苦痛 また悲しみ
悩みなのかもしれません
悩み 落ち込みに定着したままでいるというのは
このように定着しているんです
離れない だから 凡人という人がセットで 1本の槍刺されて瞬時に 2本目にもやられる
いつでもフタツ フタツ
フタツ フタツなんです
ということで そこはまた経典は続くんですけど
同じものの反対なんです
だからそこら辺 推測で計算できるとは思います
そこで聖者の弟子は も世の中で生活してるでしょ
それで野球ボールが当たる可能性はありますよ
たとえ聖者の弟子であろうと
いろんな不幸に 不幸というか
苦しみに出会うことはあります
人に怒られることやら
足が滑って転がることやら
こけることやら そんなのはあり得るんです
あるいはいたずら ものすごい悪いことをしたがっている悪ガキたちに囲まれて
いろいろいじめられたことやら
そんなのはもう普通だからあり得る
しかし それは第一の矢
第二の矢はないんです
第二の矢はないということはどういうことかというと
例えば子供たちがもういろんなことで
イススティックやら棒やら
そういうもので聖者を刺したりする
この野郎 この野郎とか
痛いかもしれません 怪我するかもしれません
でもそこで聖者は あ まあ痛みだ
怪我している それで終わっちゃうんです
何やってるんだとかね
この悪ガキはとかね そこまで怒りは丸っきり出てくる
怒りが生まれないんだから
怒りの潜在的な煩悩は生まれません
あの痛みはまあ二〜三分で消えますからね
もし子供たちが怪我させたならば
それちょっと何か薬塗っておけばもう日か日かで治りますから
それで終わり 煩悩はない
それで欲の煩悩もないし
怒りの煩悩もないし 無知の煩悩もない
それがないんだから 世の中で生きてますよ
ご飯も食べる 食べるんだけど
ああ 美味しい もっと美味しいもの食べたいっていうのは食欲はない
誰かに殴られるかもしれません
やっぱり痛いとはありますけど
何なのかと これはとか
そこはないんです だから普通
聖者も普通の人間と全く同じ世の中で生きているんです
だからお釈迦様の経典始まる時は
あれ これ何？という調子で始めたんです
凡人は苦は感じる 楽は感じる
苦不苦不楽は感じる 聖者は苦は感じる
楽は感じる 苦不苦不楽は感じる
あれ何やという調子で始めたのはそういうわけなんです
ということは 凡人であろうか
聖者であろうか ごく普通に世の中で生きています
しかし 凡人には必ずしも世間から来る矢はセットで来るんです
聖者には本で終わります
その本の矢の来たらどういったことはない
何のこともない すぐ解決するってもんだ
ということで そこら辺で終わりと思います
最後ですね はい それで私たちはどのように
ちょっと待ってください
いろいろ書くところあると思います
あと ほんの少々 どのように生きるべきかとね
このどうやって この第2番目の矢に刺されないように生きるかっていう
これはやっぱり修行しなきゃ無理かもしれませんだけど
特にヴィパッサナー瞑想でいい加減観察しろと言ってるでしょ
評価するなりに 私って偉いでしょうとか
瞑想進んでるでしょうとかね
私に聞くんじゃなくて
ありのままに観察しなさいと
そこは第2の矢をなくす方法なんですよ
やがてそれしかできなくなるんです
痛みが生まれたら痛み
だから何っていうことはなくなっちゃうんです
だって原因があって痛いんだから
原因消えたら消えますから
そういうことで楽しくなったら楽しみ
別にそれどうっていうことはなくなっちゃうんです
だから その免れる方法っていうのは
ヴィパッサナーでおっしゃってる観察方法で他の方法はないんですよ
ヴィパッサナーはいきなり突然
聖者の思考パターンを叩き込むんですよ
聖者の悟った人の思考パターン
生き方 だからみんな納得しないんですね
超能力もくれてくれないかとかね
これで自分が会社でちょっとうまくいかない
いかないんだけど あなたのヴィパッサナー瞑想やったら
会社で仕事うまくできるようになりますよ
なりますでしょうか？とか聞いたりするんです
だから私もそうですよと言いますけど
これがいきなりこの聖者の思考パターンをね
叩き込むとしているんです
ありのままに見る それ以上一歩も進まないことにする
進んだらボンの2番目の矢
だから こういう風に生きてみたらどうですかね
我々は例えば雨が降ったってのも驚かないでしょ
今日は朝 もう太陽が日の出あったでしょ
誰か驚いた？あ 今日は太陽が上がっ
昇ってくる そう驚いた
びっくりと もうとっくに沈みかけてるでしょ
なんで誰も驚かないんですかね
もうそろそろ暗くなりますけど
我々はそんなものに驚きも何もないんですよ
太陽が昇ったらもう明るくて仕事できるんだぞとかね
太陽が沈んだら暗くて
もうもう電気つけなくちゃあかんだと
とかね こんなものには全然驚きも何もない
悲しくもならない 日の出を見てびっくりして
感情的に舞い上がったりっていうのはないでしょうに
虹を見て悲しくて落ち込んでひどい目に遭った人っていうのは一人もいない
それはなぜかというと
そっちのこと 避けられないこと
どうにもならんこと それは世の中の常です
ですから なんで人が死んじゃったら悲しくなるんですかね
おかしいでしょ そこら辺なんですよ
問題は 人が死んじゃうとえらく悲しくなっちゃうんです
誰か可愛い人でも聞いて
ちょっと話しかけてくるとえらい気分がいいんです
あれなんなのかな あれがおかしいんだと
人が死ぬことも 日の出やら日没と同じことなんですよ
常識で当たり前で なんだというぐらいのもんなんですよ
例えばおじいさん あ なんだという態度を取らなきゃ
あ なんだ 死んじゃったか
で 我々にはそれ決してできんでしょうね
家に戻ると 家が泥棒に入られて
窓ガラスを割られて大変
みんな困るでしょ あ なんだ
泥棒に入って泥棒が入ったかというふうな態度でいられますかね
もし あ なんだ この窓 この窓を開けて入ったんですかね
と思った人は矢一つでやられています
物を盗まれてるんだから
しかし  2番目はない あ
なんだというぐらいで終わっちゃいますから
あ お金持っていかれたんですかね
ああ そうか それで終わりますよ
そこでお金はあったんだけど
それは夜ご飯食べるためのお金で
これ泥棒に入られて持っていかれたら
その人もやっぱり夜食べるものないんですよ
もうお金がないんだから
それでお腹が空くですけど
それ第1の矢だけで そんな大したことはないんですよ
だから我々にできるか
その生き方は お母さん連れてて病院に行ったところで
検査 検査して検査して
まあやっぱりガンだしようと言われたら
ああそうか ガンですかと
お母さんもガンだって
そう言えますかね お母さんがのお母さんの病気はガンだって
治らないんだって 本当にそれは聖者の道なんですよ
そこにそこまでなれるまで人格を成長してほしいんです
それでお母さん ああ そうかいられるならばね
もう悟ってるんですよ
だって当たり前のことだから
そんなのは 体を持ってるならば
病気になるっていうことは当たり前
避けられないんだからね
ただわかんだな とうとう来たのかっていうぐらいで終わっちゃうんですよ
とうとう来たのか 来たのかと
ですから 私の考え方からちょっと推測してください
聖者の生き方っていうのはどれほど楽しいかと
例えば悟った息子と悟ったお母さんがいて
それで病院に行ったところで
医者がえらいもう真剣で
もうお母さんに言わないで
息子を特別の部屋に呼ばれて
実はですね ちょっとこれは悪性でかなり進行していますよと
でもう治療しない方がいいと
もしかするとあと 3ヶ月間ももたないかもと言っても
息子はそうか お母さんガンガンですかね
ってぐらいで終わると
医者がなんで失するな息子ですかと思うでしょ
そこで泣き崩れて倒れちゃって
失神して なんとか先生
治療方法ないんでしょうかとか
先生ぶん殴ったりしちゃうといい息子なんですよ
もう悟った息子 ああ そうか
なんだ がんでしたって
そこで医者がせっかくお母さんにお母さんに内緒で言ってるでしょ
その場でお母さんガンだって
大きい声で言うならば
どれほど楽しいと思いますかね
それ聞いたお母さん ああ
まあそうですか とうとう来たのか
じゃあそれでね 聞いてやれよ
あとどれぐらい残ってるかというと
1ヶ月間だと ああそう
じゃあ 1ヶ月間何かしよう
で 帰ろうということで
息子と一緒に帰るならば
あれほど美しい楽しい
世界はないんですよ これが人間に理解できないんですよ
この第2の矢にも もうものすごく束縛されて陥ってるんだから
だから仏教は無執着になれと
煩悩を捨てろと これが究極な幸福だと
雨が降ろうか 地震が起きろうが
がんになろうか 一つも珍しいことは起こりませんと
ありえないことは起こりませんよ
あ なんだ そんなもんかという状態で生きていられます
で それがあの聖者のまあ一応
苦しまない方法でサットリの境地なんです
というわけで まあできるならば頑張っていってください
そこら辺で話を終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
あの講演はこれで終わりですが
しばらく質疑応答の時間にしたいと思います
皆さん 今日の講演に何か質問などございましたら手を挙げていただければ
あの苦とか楽とかの矢だと
認識が割とわかって それを不適応があるレベルではできるかもしれないような気はするんですけども
幸福楽だとその なんていうか
見過ごしてしまって 結局第二の矢が突き刺さってくるまで何もわからなくなってるから
うん それは防御法っていうのは極めて難しいような気がするんですけども
別に同格だから同じやり方で簡単ですよ
だからそれに気づいていないと
今苦だ 今楽だ 今不苦不楽やっていうことにね
だからサティがなくなっちゃうともう終わりですよ
もう負けですから それを見逃しちゃうと
じゃあ退屈になって無知が現れ
退屈の次にまた怒りが出てきてとかね
だからまあ気をつけるっていうことです
特別な防御法ということではなくて
全部同格だから 苦も楽も不苦不楽も同格だから
その時その時サティという気づくということを入れて入れておく
我々例えば机に足を打ったんですけども
いう時に瞬時に痛みと言ってなります
もう痛みそのものになるんですけど
同じように体のいろいろ人生で出会う苦しみとか悲しみも
その出来事と瞬時に一体になる
完全に一体になる だから我々も苦しみと悲しみとそのものになっちゃうんですね
そして今 サティがもしあれば
そういういろんな出来事と苦しみとか悲しみというのと距離をこうできるものなんですか
これ距離という話じゃないんですよ
例えば私もこの何か何かに体なんかぶつかると
もう先にわかるんで これからすっごく痛くなるでしょうと
痛くなる前にもうもう発見していますよ
これ 自分にとっておかしくてたまらんですよ
時々何かにぶつかったりします
ぶつかっちゃった これから痛くなるでしょうと言って
もう痛くなってくるんですよ
だからサティの訓練しちゃうと
すっごく早く心が回転するんだからね
それで痛い時はギューッと歯を噛んでじーっといるんです
ただそれだけ 一体になってじーって言ったら
あ 消えた で それで次のことに動く
だから一体になるということは
もう一体になってしまいます
だからなんでしょうかね
それも悪くはない 別に距離をっていう
そこはね 成り立たないんです
距離をおくるんじゃなくて
まあこれが嫌な気持ちになるだろうと思って
まあ嫌な気持ちだなあって
それで観察したら それ消えてしまうんですよ
別に大胆なことはしない
聖者も凡人もごく普通にいるんだから
いろんな心配事とか そういうのは
それが出てこない うん
痛いだけで終わっちゃうんです
痛いじゃないかということまではいかないんです
例えばご飯食べて美味しいか
あ これが美味しいですよということで終わるんですけど
微妙に味を味わうんですよ
なんて美味しいですかね
というとこは行かないんです
そう言っちゃうと もう失敗しているんです
第2の矢にやられているんです
はい  サティをやってると結構面白い
面白い いろんな現象っていうのを面白く感じるっていうことがありますけど
あのそれでまあ うーん
それを面白がってるっていうのは
第2の矢になりますかね
まあ言ってみりゃ 例えば痛いっていうのも
最初はこれから痛くなるなとかっていうのはもうわかってるわけですね
うん 結構それを見続けてるっていうのは面白いことでもあると思うんですけど
あー痛くなったとかっていうのを楽しんでるとか
そういうのは第2の矢
なっちゃうかどうか  第二の矢っていうのは
次の今のトラブルから次のトラブルを作ることだから
いてーって言って痛みが消えちゃったら
別にそれから次のトラブルを作ってないでしょ
だからそれは第二の矢になってないんです
第二の矢っていうのは
さらにトラブルをどんどんどんどんどんばかく膨張することなの
例えば火がついたと それにガソリンをかけると
もう消えるわけがないで
その人がいえ 大量にかければ火は消えますよと言って
必死でガソリンをかけると
これが意味がないんですよ
だから第二の矢っていうのは
起きた不幸な出来事をで終わらないで
次から次へと作っていく
そこで繊細煩悩やらいろんなものやら出てくるんですね
だからいてと美味しいんじゃないかとかね
あ 君って可愛いんじゃないかというのでは
第二の問題は起きません
君のこの服なかなか似合いますねとかね
似合うんだったら言っちゃえばいいでしょうに
別に それから第二のということは出てこない
でも例えば あんたよく服のセンスがいいですよと
毎日見るの楽しいやと言ったところで
言われた側があ 私って結構服のセンスが良くて
みんな楽しく見ているんだぞと思っちゃうと
それ私でしょ これ苦しみになるんですよ
次の次にどうしようかと
だから淡々と うん まああなたは服のセンスはいいよ
結構可愛いよとかね これは何のこともないんです
うん  そのまま  はいはい
どうぞ 後ろの  あの まあ大体目で見る感覚
それから耳で聞く うん
大体あの まあ言葉で聞こえてきたことが
ちょっとしたことでも
それをなんかこう それを元にして
ずっとこう悪い方に膨らんで
物語を捏造していくというか
そういうことを経験して苦しむことがあるんですけど
うん そこら辺はいわゆるどういう
どこでそこを切って その風を膨らまさないように
だから この今おっしゃるのも
やっぱり第二の矢の問題なんですね
これ 第二の矢から次から次へと
この経典であったように
もうありったけの煩悩を作ってしまう
だから 例えば耳で何か聞いたら
まあ聞いたところで音で止まれと
音で止まるんですよ 見えたで止まるんですよ
うん 一番早いところで止まるんです
それで膨らんでくると
しまいには自分が破滅するんじゃないかと不安になってしまうような
一回二回やってみると
あ これがいいやということになるんですよ
で 音で止まる 音といってもちゃんと内容はわかってます
問題はないんです 内容っていうのは
論理的な 具体的な内容
例えば 人が何かちょっと不注意で一言葉言ったとします
こちらで妄想してガチャガチャガチャガチャ考えて
ものすごく妄想を膨らませたりする
でもあ 本当やと言ったところで
同時に何かあの人ちょっと疲れてるみたい
ちょっと今機嫌が悪いみたい
で どこでストップするんですよ
であ あの人ちょっと機嫌が悪いとわかったら
あ なんとか機嫌よく機嫌
機嫌よくさせようとかね
思った瞬間でまるっきり別なこと言って
あのえーとですね この間とかね
別の話できますよ それですっごく自分でうまく人生を運転しているんだと自分でわかるんだからね
だからこの第二の矢が起こる前に切った人っていうのはえらい勝ちですよ
で 問題は起こりませんし
あのトラブったり何もないんです
楽しい 楽しい 結構楽しい
はい 大山会長 はい 先ほどのお話で
あの まあ非常に苦しいとか腹が立つとか
その時にその怒りが潜在意識に入って
潜在意識の中に完全に定着したと
そうすると死んでもその潜在意識に入って
もう一回持ち越されて来世になる
そこでまた嫌なことがあって
また大きく膨らんで また潜在意識に入る
同じことが繰り返される
その時に 例えばあるショーで今こうやっていただいた時に
ヴィパッサナーをやることによって
過去に積んだそういう心の潜在的な潜在意識の中のまた悪い癖とか
そういうものが自然に消えていくのか
だからこれが編み込まれている現象だから
一つ倒れると全部倒れますよ
百二十回ぐらい百四十回ぐらい大きな建物を作ったってもの
アメリカのなんとか建物みたいに
ワールドトレードセンターみたいに一本崩れたら全部ガタガタガタッと崩れます
組み立ててるんだからね
だからこの見たところで聞いたところで切るんですよ
ヴィパッサナーそれやってますよ
全部壊れます それでもう無始なる過去から持ってきた煩悩
潜在煩悩も何のことなく見事に消えてしまうんです
それは確かです で 気づかないともう悪循環で悪循環で
もうだからそれほど怖いことはないんですよ
怒りが潜在的にしてたら
まあ次からまた悪い結果になっちゃうし
輪廻転生になってまた悪いところに生まれて
また悪いことに出会っちゃうと
どんどんもう悪循環になるんです
そこでサティっていうことを入れる
入れたら何のことなく壊れてしまう
あれほど馬鹿でかいものでしたのにという １
本で壊れる まあこう考えれば
例えばもうもう何年もかけてかけて
あるいは何百何億年もかけて
人が巨大なドミノの作ったと組み立てたと １
本倒れれば全部倒れちゃいますから
そんな感じなんです  他にございますでしょうか
あと 最後の病院で病院でがんになって
死を宣告されても続いていられるっていうお話が最後にありましたけれども
そこがまあ最終形というか
まあやはりいろんな苦しみとかを消そう消そうとしても
死にたくないっていう気持ちは皆さん持っていると思うんですけど
そこが一番ゴールというか
そこを越えてしまった段階で終わりなんでしょうか
死んでも別に死が怖くなくなるっていうのが
その仏教でいう解脱のちょっと目安というか
まあ一つの表現ですけど
あの一般人がね 苦しみを消そう消そうとしてるでしょ
悟った人が世の中にいる場合はね
何でも当たり前で見てしまうんです
だから感情はね だから何と
別に面白くも何でもないんではないかと
というか 珍しくも何でもないんではないかと
だから我々の立場から見れば
死だけはそれだけはごめんという状態だから
私の例えはちょっとまあ心に引っかかるかもしれません
お母ちゃん お母ちゃんガンだったっていう話はね
でも どんなものについてあっても同じアプローチなんです
というか 死 もうどうったことないんでしょう
そちらで理解したければ
そういうふうに理解したってもいいんですよ
まあ私たちにもそれなりに会社で給料下げたと
まあそれぐらいのこと我慢できるぞと
で でも死ぬぞと言っちゃったら
ちょっと我々には でも聖者にはそれさえもできますよというふうに理解しても構いません
あ 死ぬのかというぐらいのことなんです
うん いわゆる論理的には簡単ですよ
この世の中で珍しいものっていうのは現れません
何が出来上がったっても
ちゃんと原因があって現れるものなんですよ
壊れるものも ある日突然壊れるってことはないんですよ
ちゃんと原因があって壊れるんですよ
だから因果法則で見ると当たり前なんです
なんだかんだ ああ 大変だ
どうしようかっていうことは成り立たない
それで死っていうことも
まあ別に当たり前で 生まれるということも当たり前で
そこを見ると執着から心が離れるんです
そこら辺ちょっと難しいんですから
今おっしゃった通りに理解しても構いません
うん はい  問題を解決するのに
自分の五感を信頼して行動するところが思うようにいかない
そうしたらまたやり直す
また失敗する またやり直す
この繰り返す  はだから一回失敗して
またやり直し 失敗するとやり直してないんですよ
繰り返しただけだからね
繰り返しは認めないで
仏教は 繰り返しはできないんです
時々そこら辺ちょっとはっきりしてください
皆様にそれは役に立つと思います
例えば 私の話は完璧じゃないんだから
じゃあ失敗してもやり直せばいいやと繰り返せばいいやということは完全な教えじゃないんです
繰り返しやり直しはないんです
もし自分が同じことを繰り返したならば
自分が間違っているんです
物事は変化するんですよ
1 秒も止まっていないんです
だから 一つをやってみて
失敗したら 似ている結果を出したければ
次にまた頑張ってみますが
その時は全く新しい仕事で新しいチャレンジなんです
その調整がないとまた失敗する
去年やった通りにやりましょうと言っちゃうと失敗する
去年はもう終わった 今日
今年は今年だと その子の物事をずっと流れているんだから
そこら辺もちょっと配慮しないと
例えば試験落第しますね
もう一度同じパターンで受けると失敗しますよ
その場合は その人はもう間違い
すごい間違いを犯しているんですね
でも  2回目試験を受ける場合は 1
回目受けた経験もあるし
長い間勉強した経験もあるし
それからプラスアルファで欠けているもの
時間なくて勉強できなかったもの
あまりにも理解できなかったポイントとかね
そこら辺合わせて勉強すればいいでしょ
2回目のチャレンジで
それで 2回目はもう合格する可能性はあります
まるっきり同じパターンでいっちゃうと
これは法則違反ですよ
それは 1年経っているのに
私は今 五十八ですけど
一年経ってもいえ 五十八だよということと同じなんで
嘘ですからね その場合は
二年経ってもいえ 五十八ですよと
こんなのありえないでしょうに
年取るんだからね だから時間は変わってますので
同じことを繰り返すということではないというポイントを覚えておいてください
でないととんでもないことになるんです
例えば この野球やらスポーツやらいろんなもので
このもう何万回も同じ訓練させるでしょ
これを八回やりなさいとかね
一日一万回打ってみなさいとかね
同じことじゃないんですよ
一回一回違うんです その人一回一回違うんだそうと頭で認識するんだったら
一日千回とか打つ必要ないんです
すぐ身についちゃうんです
早くも 一回一回違うんだよと覚えておけば
これがみんな忘れます
無常っていうのはみんな忘れるんです
だから無知というんですよ
だから失敗する 無常っていうことをわかっておけば
毎日才能が向上します
毎日向上します すごく苦労して文章を書けたとしますね
二番 二回 二回目書く場合はもう経験の積みだから違うものを書ける
それで三回目はもっと違う
だから書くたびに 文章でもそれなりに進んでいくはずなんです
似ている訓練で 野球訓練みたいな
全く同じことでも 繰り返すことによって能力は向上するんです
理由は無常だからなんです
リピート不可能だからなんです
それそれで覚えやすいと思います
人生というか 世の中で何一つもリピートは不可能です
それを覚えて頑張っちゃうとうまくいくと思います
他にございますでしょうか
...一応最後にそういうことで
今日は本当に役に立つようにと思っては喋りましたけど
結局は失敗しました すみませんだけど
簡単です このポイントを覚えておいてください
私たちは大胆に思っている苦っていうのは
第1に書いたものはね
何のこともないんだと
それよりお釈迦様おっしゃっている苦は永遠に続くものであって
絶対的なものであって
これだけは気をつけて生活するということと
それから結論として言った
この第二の矢にやられないようにと
常に観察するというやり方で
人生は見事にうまく成功もするし
しかし成功することは大したことはない
悟ることなんですね 悟ると言ったっても
悟りに近寄れば寄るほど
結構楽しいというか 面白いというか
だから最後に言っただって
お母ちゃん頑張ってという風な言葉を覚えておいてください
もしそう言われるならば
聞いてる  お母ちゃんダメだったら言えませんだけど
で もし二人とも悟ってるんだったら
お母ちゃんも ああ そうか
あと聞いてください あと何ヶ月かと
そんな調子だったら あの親子っていうのは結構楽しいでしょ
何のも感情的な苦しみ
悩みはないんだからね
そういうことは頭に覚えておいておけば
正しい生き方見つかると思います
ということで話を終了します
それから何でしたっけ
回向の文お願いします
回向の文 高僧の三宝に礼拝礼致し
最後の身の命とヴィパッサナー修行によって得られた功徳を
神々 先祖 祖先 養親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得られますように
サッベーテョ イダンジャンツーサッバローゴ ウィナッサトゥマーテーバワットアンテラヨースキーディーガ ユコ
ーバヴァ ババトゥサッバマンガラン ラッカントゥサッバデーヴァタ サッバ ブッダヌバーヴェーナ サッバ ダンマヌバーヴ
ェーナ サッバ サンガヌバーヴェーナ サダ スッティバヴァントゥテ アユーラ アロキヤ サンプッティ サンガ サンプッテ
ィ メーウェチェ アト ニンバーナ サンプッティ
イミナテー サミッジャトゥ
ではどうもありがとうございます
はい